Welcome to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A. My name
is JD Quinn. It's my pl my pleasure to
be able to spend this hour with you to
be able to go through these questions.
I'm so impressed with our with our team
here. I want to introduce them to you.
First of all, there's uh James Rafferty.
James in Central California right now, I
believe.
Good to be here with you, J. D, Shelley,
and Derell. Looking forward to God's
answers to our viewers questions.
Amen. Derell Thomas.
Amen. Uh, you know, in life we have a
lot of questions, but we can always find
answers in God's word. So, I'm glad to
have you here.
And you are a student. I just want to
make that I I'm impressed. And my
precious Shelley Quinn, it's good to see
you, Shelly.
Thank you, honey. Uh, we just want to
thank you for sending in your questions
because it's our privilege to get in and
dig them out. And it always helps as you
dig through the word and find out, it
helps our faith as well.
And we just mentioned how do we get
those questions? There's three ways to
receive the questions that you send in.
Number one, if you'd like to text them
in, it's uh 618-2283975.
I'll repeat those later in about 15
minutes. But uh email bible qa3abn.tv.
And if you'd like to use Instagram, it's
3ABN
official. So, we got the housekeeping
out of the way, like to start off with
prayer and then we'll just go from
there. Is that all right, guys? Sure.
Father, as we come before you in the
name of Jesus, thank you. Thank you,
Lord, that we can call upon you knowing,
Lord, that you have ears to hear, eyes
to see. Father, these are wonderful
questions, and we're just asking, Lord,
that we be emptied of self, filled with
the Holy Spirit, Lord, and the right
words come out. We love you. We thank
you and we give you praise and glory in
the name of Jesus. Amen.
Amen.
We're going to start with James. We're
going to go with James, Terrell, then
Shelley, then James, etc. Again, your
first question, James, why does God
mention a new heaven and a new earth? I
can completely understand the importance
of needing a new earth, but why a new
heaven? This is from Mike in Michigan.
Well, Mike, thank you for your question.
Uh, we have in the Bible three heavens
actually. We have our immediate
atmosphere where birds fly and where we
see the sun and the moon. That's uh
Revelation 6:14 for example tells us
that. Then we have the second heaven is
like beyond the immediate heavens. We
get up into um the atmosphere. We see um
all of the galaxies and the stars and
the planets. And then finally, we have a
third heaven. That's where we actually
go into the very presence of God. When
we talk about heaven, sometimes in the
Bible, we're talking about where God
actually dwells, not the space where the
where the planets and the um galaxies
are and not our immediate heavens where
we see the sun and the moon and the
birds flying. So when we talk about the
new heavens, we know that this
definitely refers to our immediate
heaven, part of the creation of the
earth. We know it's going to be
transformed because before the flood, it
was understood from scripture that we
had an atmosphere of water that
enveloped this planet and that the
original atmosphere allowed people to
live much longer and plants to grow much
bigger. And it seems this will be
restored as part of the new heavens and
the new earth. But we also understand
there's a lot of junk being sent out to
space nowadays. You know, got satellites
out there and they just kind of they
they fail and they kind of left out
there and and we know that the stuff is
sent out to space just to get rid of it.
And so we know God's going to have to
clean up space, that second heaven.
However, we can add that just because
the Bible says so. And I just want to
emphasize this. We're going to go to the
Bible. Now, the third heaven where God
dwells is also going to be made new.
Now, what do we mean by that? Well,
let's take a look at some verses here in
Revelation 21 1-3. John says, "And I saw
a new heaven and a new earth, for the
first heaven and the first earth were
passed away, and there was no more sea."
So we see that as the immediate heavens
where the birds fly. Verse two. And I,
John, saw the holy city, the new
Jerusalem, coming down from God out of
heaven. That's the third heaven. That
heaven coming from God out of heaven.
Prepared as a bride adorned for her
husband. Verse three. And I heard a
great voice out of heaven. That's where
God dwells. Saying, "Behold, the
tabernacle of God is with men." I mean,
we got a big U-Haul here taking place.
and he's going to dwell with them and
they're going to be his people and God
himself shall be with them and he'll be
their God. So the making of the new
heavens and the new earth includes God
making his move from the third third
heaven to the first heaven. I mean
talking about making things new. God is
going to dwell with us right here on
planet earth. The planet that went into
rebellion against God is going to become
the very center of his universe. So that
if anyone wants to see God, he has to
come to planet earth. They have to come
to planet earth. What a powerful
testimony of God's grace and God's love.
So I think it covers all three heavens.
Uh to be honest with you, I hope uh I
really hope Mike that that helps to
answer your question.
Amen. That's good. Derell, your first
question. Revelation 22:5 states that
there will be no night in heaven and God
never sleeps or slumbers.
So will we sleep in heaven? And this is
from Darlene in Arizona. Well, thank you
Darlene for your question. Um, and to be
honest, the Bible doesn't spell that out
specifically as to whether we will sleep
in heaven. But to to answer this
question, uh, let's consider what sleep
is in the first place. See, every day
the body needs to be repaired and sleep
allows the body and brain to repair
themselves. And every human is subject
to this need. Jesus showed that he had
this need as well when he was sleeping
in the back of a boat in Mark 4:38. And
Hebrews 4:15 plainly states that he
understands our weaknesses for he faced
all of the same testings we do, yet he
did it without sin. And so these
weaknesses include things like weariness
uh according to John 4:6, hunger
according to Matthew 4:2, and thirst
according to John 19:28.
It also included death. Although death
could not hold him forever from uh
Romans 6:9 confirms that Christ was
raised from the dead and he will never
die again and death no longer has any
power over him. So Christ no longer is
subject to any of these weaknesses. But
what does that mean for us? The Bible
tells us in 1 John 3:2 that when he,
that is Jesus, is revealed, that's at
his second coming, we shall be like him,
for we shall see him as he is. And to
build on this, Philippians 3 21 also
says that at his return, Jesus will take
our weak mortal bodies and change them
into glorious bodies like his own. So
what what this will look like, we can
only imagine. But one thing we do know
is that human frailty will be forgotten
thing, a forgotten thing of the past.
Hallelujah. So even when we eat from the
tree of life, the Bible clearly states
that it will not be out of hunger as we
know it today. For the Bible says we
will neither hunger anymore nor thirst
anymore according to Revelation 7:16.
So with no more need of hunger or thirst
to survive, could it be that we will no
longer need sleep either? While the
Bible, as I said before, does not give
us a definitive answer, we can at least
infer that we will not need sleep to
survive in in eternity. According to
Luke 20:36, when Jesus returns and
changes us to be like him, just as he c
he can no longer die, we also cannot die
anymore, being sons of the resurrection.
In other words, all human frailty will
have been conquered for all of eternity.
Amen.
Here's here's one more point. Our
earthly sleepwake cycle is usually
controlled by the sun and to some degree
the moon. Revelation 21:23 tells us that
the city of God will have no need of the
sun or of the moon to shine in it for
the glory of God illuminated it. And it
says the lamb is its light. So can we
sleep in heaven? Who knows what will be
possible? But will we need to sleep in
heaven? The evidence seems to point to
the answer being no.
Amen.
That's good. Never thought about that.
Shelly,
what is the difference between the soul,
the spirit, and the breath when someone
dies? Do these elements return to God
upon death? And what does he do with
them? This is from Elizabeth. Elizabeth,
this is such an important question
because it is identifying what it means
to live and die and have hope in Christ.
So the soul, the Bible teaches that man
became a living soul, not that he was
has a soul. Genesis 2:7, the Lord God
formed man of the dust of the ground and
breathed into the nostrils the breath of
life and man became a living soul. So
the soul is a combination of the body or
the dust of the ground and the breath of
life. Now let me there's two words that
we use as breath in scripture. In
Hebrew, the nashama is the lifegiving
breath, the energy from God. And so body
plus the breath of life is a soul. And
when a person dies, that combination
ceases and the soul, the living person
no longer exists until the resurrection.
The spirit in the in the Hebrew ruach in
the Greek numa. When you see spirit with
a little S, it can also and it often
means the breath of life. It's a life
principle. It does not represent a
disembodied
unconscious soul or conscious soul. In
Genesis 7:22,
it says, "All in whose nostrils was the
breath," that's the nishima
of the spirit of life, that's ruach,
that's the life principle. All that was
on the dry land died. So in context,
it's talking about the cattle had this
breath, spirit of life. Man had that and
they all died. All the beast. Job 27:3
says, "All the while my breath is in me
and the spirit, the ruach of God is in
my nostrils." The breath of life, that
life principles in the nostrils. What
happens at death? Ecclesiastes 12 tells
us the that the dust or the body returns
to the earth as it was and the spirit
the ruach the breath will return to God
who gave it. So at death the body
returns to the dust dust to dust and the
breath or the life force returns to God.
The soul ceases to exist. Now please
understand the spirit is not a conscious
entity. It's simply a divine life force.
So this would be like electricity
returning to its source. God does not
store a conscious human being. He
retains the life record, the identity,
the character in his divine memory.
Waiting for the resurrection day when he
will restore life. So at death, the body
returns to dust, the spirit, the breath
life force returns to God and the soul
ceases to exist.
Amen. Very good. James, your second
question. When Jesus went to heaven some
days after his resurrection, he went
into the holy place. According to the
Seventh Day Adventist Church, he moved
to the most holy place in 1844.
Some refute this because when Jesus
died, the veil was torn from top to
bottom, meaning that there is no holy
place and most holy place. But one room
since the curtain was removed. In other
words, there's one room since the
curtain was removed. Why then are there
still endless discussions going on in
the church about this? Is the Bible not
clear on this subject? And this is from
Maurice in Belgium.
Thank you, Maurice in Belgium. Let's
just start with the first part of that
question or the last part. Yes, the
Bible is crystal clear on this subject.
However, some translations of the Bible
are not so clear. Some translations of
Hebrews 9:12, for example, have Christ
going into the most holy place at his
ascension, placing a question mark on
1844 in the judgment. Those translations
would be the NIV and the New King James
Bible. Now, it's always good to ask
questions when we find translation
variations that have major implications
like this one does. So, did Jesus enter
the most holy place at his ascension?
You know, the Bible is clear, but some
versions are not clear. And that is one
reason why we recommend you to come to
SAD, that is school of disciplehip. It's
our school of disciplehip at 3ABN and we
teach you how to use a strong exhaustive
concordance and how to look at the Greek
and the Hebrew language. Now we have a
sod class coming up. If you go to
3abnsaw.com
you come you can get more information.
That's 3ABNsaw.com.
Let's take a look though at Hebrews
chapter 9 1-3. So it says in verse one,
then verily the first covenant had also
ordinances of divine service and a
worldly sanctuary. That's the earthly
sanctuary. Verse two, there was also a
tabernacle, excuse me, there was a
tabernacle made, the first wherein, that
is the first or holy uh place of the
tabernacle, wherein was the candlestick,
the table, and the showbread, which is
called the sanctuary. Hagon, that's what
the word sanctuary means in the Greek,
hagon. Verse three, after the second
veil, the tabernacle which is called the
holiest of all. Now the word the phrase
there holiest of all is actually in the
Greek hagon for holiest of hagon. All
should actually be translated hagon. So
you've got hagon hagon describing the
most holy place. What is very vital for
us to understand is that that phrase
hagon hagon that double use is never
used again in the book of Hebrews. So
when you go to Hebrews chapter 9:12
where it says neither by the blood of
goats and calavs but by his own blood he
entered in once into the holy place
that's hagion having obtained eternal
redemption for us the translations that
put most holy place the NIV the new King
James translation there's no Greek
support for that there's no huggy on
huggy on there so we're very thankful
that Paul has clarified the most holy
place in verses two and three so that we
can understand the difference between
the two in the Greek and then get
clarification of their mistransations in
other parts of Hebrews like in Hebrews
9:12. Now, what about the veil being
torn from top to bottom, meaning there's
no more holy place or most holy place in
the heavenly? This is actually an
assumption. The Bible doesn't say
anything about a veil in heaven. It did
happen in the earthly sanctuary as an
indication that the earthly system of
sacrifice was ending. So why are there
still needless endless discussions in
the SDA church about Jesus going to the
holy place and the most holy place?
Well, primarily because if there is no
curtain between though there is a
curtain between the two rooms, if there
is no curtain between the holy most holy
place, then you would be confused about
what Christ is doing there. Even if
there is no curtain, there is still the
two phases. There's the first phase in
the holy place which represents his
sacrifice and his priestly intercession.
And then there's the second phase, the
final phase in the most holy which
represents his sacrifice, his priestly
mediation and his judgment or his time
of judgment. So in the most holy place,
Christ has transitioned to sacrifice,
mediator, and judge. In the holy place,
it was sacrifice and mediator. And of
course, in the courtyard, he is
sacrificed. So the sanctuary lays out
the plan of salvation beautifully. The
gospel, he comes as a sacrifice. Phase
one, courtyard. He goes to heaven into
the holy place. Phase two, ministry and
sacrifice. And then he moves into the
most holy place after 1844. Phase three,
final phrase. Phase sacrifice,
mediation, and judge.
Very good.
Really good. James Derell number two.
The disciples waited until after the
Sabbath for the preparation of Jesus'
body. Does that mean that we shouldn't
have funerals or go to funerals on the
Sabbath? This is from Marie in
Pennsylvania.
You know, that's a thoughtful and an
important question to answer because a
funeral service is a sacred occasion
that honors the life of loved ones and
comforts grieving hearts. But should a
such a ser service be held on the
Sabbath? Based on scripture, I
understand that while Sabbath funerals
may occasionally occur, they should be
the exception and not the norm. The
biblical norm is presented in the story
you mentioned which is in Luke chapter
23 where Joseph of Arythea requested the
body of Jesus. In verse 53 we pick up
where it says then he took it down
speaking of the body of Jesus wrapped it
in linen and laid it in a tomb that was
heuned out of the rock where no one had
ever lain before. That day was the
preparation and the Sabbath drew near.
And the women who had come with him from
Galilee followed after, and they
observed the tomb and how his body was
laid. Then they returned and prepared
spices and fragrant oils, and they
rested on the Sabbath according to the
commandment.
So these verses show that the burial was
completed before the Sabbath began. The
body was wrapped in linen. Jesus was
transported to and placed in the tomb.
And the tomb was closed and sealed
according to Mark 15:46.
And because of timing, certain tasks
were left until after the Sabbath had
concluded. The washing of the body of
Jesus, the anointing of the body with
fragrant oils and spices. In today's
funerals, the washing and anointing are
typically replaced by the inbombing
process and cosmetic preparation.
However, other parts of the of the
funeral still involve labor intensive
work such as the transport of the body,
staff working um on that day, the burial
logistics that have to take place, all
of which raise questions when these are
scheduled for the Sabbath. Funeral home
staff must work and be paid, as well as
anyone else who works on the day. Though
the grave is usually prepared before the
funeral, the the day of the funeral, the
transport and burial of the body
typically involves more elements of
labor. The key question is, do these
things need to happen on the Sabbath? In
most cases, the answer is no. Therefore,
out of respect for God's command to rest
on the Sabbath, it is preferable to hold
funerals on another day. However, if
circumstances are beyond your control, I
believe scripture does not require you
to avoid attending. In such cases, be
prayerful and respectful. Let love and
sympathy guide your actions. Grief is a
sacred burden, and offering comfort to
the mourning can still be done in a way
that honors the Sabbath. Always
remember, according to Matthew 12:12,
that it is lawful to do good on the
Sabbath. And according to 2 Corinthians
1:es 3 and 4, blessed be the God and
father of our Lord Jesus Christ, the
father of mercies and the God of all
comfort, who comforts us in our
tribulation, so that we may be able to
comfort those who are in any trouble
with the comfort with which we ourselves
are comfort comforted by God.
Amen.
Amen. That's good, Shelly. Number two,
2 Colossians 2:16 says, "Therefore, do
not let anyone judge you by what you eat
or drink or with regard to a religious
festival, a new moon celebration, or a
Sabbath day." Seems like it's saying it
does not matter the day that we rest.
Please explain.
Uh, that's such a wonderful question
because what this proves is you always
have to read the Bible in context. It is
confusing if you just pluck that out. In
context, it's talking about what was
nailed to the cross. There were three
things I see that the Bible identifies
that Jesus nailed to the cross. First
Peter 2:24, it says, "Christ himself
bore our sins in his own body on the
tree that we having died to sins might
live for righteousness by whose stripes
you were healed." So, he paid our sin
debt. Our indebtedness, that certificate
of indebtedness was nailed to the cross
when he died. Um, Romans 6:6 says, Paul
says, "Our old man was crucified with
him. He nailed our old sin nature to the
when we're in Christ, we're new
creations in him." And then, uh, what
was else else was nailed to the cross?
Now we get to Colossians 2, but rather
than looking just at verse 16, let's
read 14-1
17. He says, "Having wiped out the
handwriting of requirements that was
against us, which was contrary to us, he
has taken it out of the way. Having
nailed it to the cross, having disarmed
principalities and powers, he made a
public spectacle of them, triumphing
over them in it." So in other words,
here's what he did and here's the
conclusion.
Since this was nailed to the cross, let
no one judge you in food or drink or
regarding a festival or a new moon or
Sabbath which are a shadow of things to
come, but the substance is of Christ.
The food and drink offerings, the
festivals and the annual Sabbaths that
were part of those festivals all
symbolically shadowed the ministry of
Jesus Christ. They were all recorded in
the old covenant, the book of the law,
the which is found in Deuteronomy. And
it also listed the curses for
disobedience. It was put on a side
pocket pocket of the ark rather than
inside the ark like the ten
commandments. And it was there God said
as a witness against them. So with the
everlasting
blood of the covenant or the blood of
the everlasting covenant that Jesus shed
on Calvar's cross, those commandments
contained in ordinances were abolished.
Ephesians 2:13-16
also says this, "Christ abolished in his
flesh the law of commandments contained
in ordinances that he could reconcile
Jew and Gentile to him in the new or
renewed covenant." So what was not
nailed to the cross, it is so clear that
God's moral law, the ten commandments
were not nailed to the cross. They are
part of the new covenant. Just they were
at the heart of the old covenant.
They're at the heart of the new
covenant. Hebrews 8:10, he God says that
he will write those laws in in this new
covenant. He writes them on our minds
and places them on our hearts. So the
the weekly Sabbath is still intact.
Amen.
Amen. Good. I'd mentioned earlier that
we were going to uh be able to share the
contact information again. In other
words, how to get the questions to 3ABN.
Uh if you want to text 6182283975.
If you'd like to email them, that's
biblea
3abn.tv.
And if you want to Instagram, it's 3ABN
official.
James, now let's go to your third
question. Could you explain the seven
churches of revelation? And this is from
Cindy in West Virginia.
Well, Cindy in West Virginia, we want to
recommend that you go to our website and
find the program salvation and symbols
and signs. Uh you'll get a much deeper
explanation there than we can give in
just three minutes. But the seven
churches of revelation are parallel.
What? Let me say it this way. They are
they have two meanings. One is they
represent seven periods of church
history from the apostolic age all the
way down to the close of time. They also
represent in their description of the
experience of God's people uh our own
experiences. Sometimes you can read the
church of Ephesus or you can read the
church of uh Pergamus and you can relate
to some of the things that those
churches are going through. That's what
we understand to be um a application of
prophecy that is present truth for us
right now. So when we look at the
churches Ephesus that word means
desirable you we usually understand that
to be representing the church period
from AD.31 to AD 100 the apostolic age
where they were going forth conquering
and to conquer. Uh that church period
was uh fulfilled in the early church.
And then we go to Smyrna. Right after
that age finished AD 100 about 8313 we
have Smyrna mean bittersweet myrr has to
do with uh the kind of um uh um uh um
stuff I can't think of the word right
now that they embomb people with. So
it's talking about uh death. There's
language there that's referring to
death. Myrr used to embomb dead bodies.
um spices that's the word I'm using for
this is a time when the church is
heavily persecuted and then we go to
Pergamus now Pergamus picks up in 313
moves into about 538 that is the age of
Constantine and this is when the church
is elevated and that word Pergamus means
acropolis or elevation the church is
elevated in the world during that period
of Pergamus and you find that
description of compromise in the context
of that church uh then we have Thotyra
which means sacrifice dependence and
that is about AD538 to AD1517. It's the
dark ages when millions of people were
sacrificed for their faith and then God
also gave the church time to repent and
of course that door closed in about
1798. Go into more details go to
salvation symbols and signs. Then we
move to Sardis that means escaping AD
1517 to AD 1798. This is the time of
reformation when they come out of the
dark ages. They escape out of the dark
ages. Then you have Philadelphia. That
word represents brotherly love. And
that's about 1798 to the 1850s. We have
a missionary age. We have the Millerite
movement. We have a a huge
transformation of the church. A
beautiful reformation that took place in
the context of that time period. And
then we move to the final church, the
seventh church AD 1815 to the end of the
world. It's the age of compromise. It's
the age of judgment. The people judge is
what the word leadya means. So all of
these church ages are being fulfilled.
All of them taking us down to the very
end of time. We are in the leadyan age,
the time of judgment right now.
Amen.
It's a lot of stuff there.
Derel, your third question. Does Satan
have the power to resurrection?
Let me repeat that again. Does Satan
have the power to resurrect the dead to
life? And this is from Anthony in Ohio.
Thank you, Anthony, for your question.
And the short answer to your question is
no. Satan does not possess the ability
to either create life or to restore life
because that power belongs to God alone.
Jesus demonstrated this divine ability
while he was on the earth. And as he
approached the tomb of Lazarus, he told
Martha, "I am the resurrection and the
life. He who believes in me, though he
may die, he shall live." According to
John 11:25. In other words, Jesus didn't
just perform resurrections. He is the
resurrection. Within himself was the
power not only to heal the sick, forgive
sins, and cast out devils, but also to
raise the dead. He also told his
disciples in John 14:6, "I am the way,
the truth, and the life. No man cometh
unto the father but by me."
And this verse speaks not only of a
spiritual access to God or coming to God
but the eventual physical resurrection
of the body when we will be brought into
the physical presence of God. So for
those who die in Christ, Jesus is the
only way back to the father through the
resurrection of the body. Now while
prophets and disciples in scripture also
raised the dead, they didn't possess the
power inherently within themselves. They
relied entirely on God to perform the
miracle for them. For example, Elijah
prayed, "Oh Lord, my God, please let
this child's life return to him."
According to First Kings 17:21,
then Elisha prayed to the Lord before
raising the Shunomite son in 2 Kings
4:33.
Peter knelt down and prayed before
raising Dorcas in Acts Acts chapter 9.
And although Acts chapter 20 doesn't
explicitly say that Paul prayed before
raising Udicus back to life, the pattern
suggests that he also sought God's power
to raise up Udicus. Even Jesus before
raising Lazarus prayed. But in his case,
he didn't do it to get power or
permission to raise Lazarus. He said in
Johnap 11 14 41 and 42. Father I thank
you that you have heard me but because
of the people who are standing by I said
this that they may believe that you sent
me. So his prayer was for the crowd's
sake not for divine help to raise
Lazarus because the power to give life
was already Christ's by nature. That
brings us back to Satan. Since
resurrection power belongs to God alone,
Satan would have to ask God for it. And
the answer is still no as to whether
Satan has the power to resurrect. For
God would never give the enemy that
authority. And even in the second
resurrection described in Revelation
chapter 20, when the wicked are raised
to face judgment, it is still God who
brings them back to life and not Satan.
Therefore, no one but God has the power
to raise the dead back to life.
Amen.
Good answer.
Shelley,
your third question. Could you explain 2
Corinthians 12:2? And this is from
Garfield in Jamaica.
Garfield, this is a good question. And
again, it's a good example of always
studying in context. Let's read it. 2
Corinthians 12:2, Paul writes, "I know a
man in Christ who 14 years ago, whether
in the body I do not know, or whether
out of the body, I do not know. God
knows." Such a one was caught up to the
third heaven. Here Paul is humbly
referring to himself
in the third person. How do we know
that? Because we look within context.
Just a few scriptures down verse verse 7
he continues and he said unless I be
exalted above measure. So he's
indicating he was the one who was caught
up to heaven in the third heaven in
vision. So what does whether in the body
or out of the body mean? Paul is
describing the mysterious
nature of a vision. He's unclear whether
he was physically taken up to heaven or
if it happened only in vision while his
body remained on earth. You know, the
same thing happened to other biblical
prophets. Daniel saw visions and Daniel
10 8-10 said he fell as though asleep.
John, Revelation 1:10 tells us was in
the spirit caught up in vision. Ezekiel
in Ezekiel 8:3, he was taken by the
spirit to distant places in vision. So,
let me make this crystal clear. Paul is
not talking about astral projection.
He's not talking about an outofbody
experience. It's just that the vis
vision was so real, he couldn't tell if
it was physical or merely spiritual. So
what is the third heaven in biblical
cosmology? James already hit on this a
little, but the first heaven is earth's
atmosphere. We find that in Genesis
1:20. The second heaven is outer space.
This is Psalm 19:E1.
The third heaven is God's dwelling pre
place, the true paradise. 2 Corinthians
12:4 and Revelation 2:7. So Paul was
caught up in vision to the very presence
of God and he was receiving prophetic
inspiration. You know, Amos 3:7 says,
"Surely the Lord does nothing unless he
reveals his secrets to the servants, the
pro his servants, the prophets." And
Paul truly was such a servant. He was
entrusted with a glimpse of heaven while
grounded in truth on earth.
Amen. Wow.
Amen.
It's a great These are great answers.
James, your fourth question. What is the
investigative judgment? This is from DJ
in Oklahoma.
Well, that is a great question, DJ. You
know, there's a lot of controversy over
the investigative judgment. Just want to
encourage you that if you'd like more
information on this uh 3ABN is offering
a book for free right now for a limited
time. You can get a copy of the book
called The uh Silencing the Accuser. Uh
a gospel investigation of the
investigative judgment. And in this
book, we show from scripture what the
investigative judgment is all about. It
starts in Romans chapter 14:es 10
through13. And it talks about how God
has a day of judgment so that we can
stop judging one another. Stop judging
people. I'll take care of all of the uh
injustice that's taking place on planet
Earth and all the injustices taking
place within the Christian church or
within those who profess Christianity.
Matthew 7:21-23 tells us that there are
many who profess to follow God but
aren't really true followers, heart
followers. They're just professors. And
God recognizes that and God will judge
Christian hypocrites. He'll take care of
that. So that's what the Bible is
teaching when it comes to the
investigative judgment in relationship
to the church and professed believers.
But also, we're told in Revelation 12:10
that God wants to silence the accuser of
the brethren. We have a 24/7 365 accuser
who's accusing us day and night. Doesn't
take vacations, doesn't take sick leave,
doesn't take holidays. He's on us and
you know that. And so one of the reasons
why God has a judgment is to silence the
accusations of Satan against his people.
Only God can do that because God will
present his righteousness in Jesus
Christ to defend those who put their
trust in him. And then we see in the
context of the Bible that the
investigative judgment also includes
God. that God is in this with us. And we
see that in many different places. If
you want a theological perspective on
this, you can look at Revelation 11 and
verse one. And of course, Revelation 14
and verse 7 talks about the hour of his
judgment coming, which includes God. And
why is God included in the judgment?
Well, because God is saving us. And so,
Satan accuses God as well as us. So we
can see this for example in Luke chapter
7 when the Jesus is at a a feast in his
honor and the woman comes and anoints
his feet with oil and this woman of
course is a sinner and Simon says in his
heart if this man were a prophet he
would know what kind of woman this is
for she's a sinner. So you have Jesus
and the woman which represents us the
woman symbolic of a church who stands
behind Jesus in the judgment. Both of
them are being accused. So this is the
bigger picture of the judgment. We need
to understand also according to Romans
chapter 8 27 that God is searching our
hearts and that word search means to
investigate. That's right. The word
investigate is actually a biblical word.
It's found not only in the New
Testament, Romans 8:27 and Romans
Revelation 2:23, but it's also found in
the Old Testament all through the
Psalms. You can look at Psalm 26:2 and
Psalm uh um 17:3. You have all of these
different references that talk about God
searching or investigating our hearts.
Why? Let's close with this one verse.
Psalm 139:23 and 24. Search me, oh God,
and know my heart. Try me. Investigate
me and know my thoughts to see if there
be any wicked way in me and to lead me
in the way after everlasting. God is
investigating because God wants to get
all the rubbish out. And according to
Micah chapter 7, he wants to dump it in
the depths of the sea. And he wants to
put up a sign that says, "No fishing."
The investigative judgment is all about
God making us spotless, presenting us
spotless so that he can make a judgment
in our favor in the heavenly sanctuary
and save us for all eternity.
And I have to just add a little note
here. You've got to get this book. It's
one of the most beautiful presentations.
James was the author on the
investigative judgment. It's called
Silencing the Accuser. You can call our
3AB and call center and get this
beautiful book that will bring such joy
to your heart when you think about the
investigative judgment.
Amen.
Thank you, Shel.
Derell, your fourth question. Will I
still have eternal life with Christ if I
get cremated? This is from Cindy in
Washington. Thank you, Cindy, for your
question and it certainly deserves a
biblical and a careful answer.
In in biblical times, cremation was
uncommon among God's people. It wasn't
forbidden, but generally speaking, it
was reserved for judgment and on rare
occasions.
Uh, with that said, let me state clearly
from the start that cremation does not
prevent anyone from receiving eternal
life.
Amen. Cremation will put no one out of
heaven just as readily as burial will
put no one into heaven.
Now, now that we've gotten that point
clear, uh let's unpack why this is so.
Our hope in Christ is not dependent on
how our physical body is handled after
death, but how we live our lives before
death.
In Matthew uh 7:20 it says, "Wherefore
by their fruits ye shall know them and a
person produces fruit when they are
living and they are making choices upon
the earth. But after death, the Bible
says in Ecclesiastes 9:es 5 and 6 that
the dead know nothing.
Never more will they have any share in
anything done under the sun, including
what is done with their body."
Then 2 Corinthians 5:10 says that each
person will be judged for the life that
they have lived not what happened to
their body after they died. In biblical
times while uh we like I mentioned
earlier burial was common practice the
most common practice especially among
the followers of God. Abraham, Sarah,
Isaac, Rebecca, Jacob and Leah were all
buried in the same cave. David was
buried in a tomb as well as many other
kings. And even Jesus himself was buried
because burial honors the belief in a
future resurrection most closely while
preserving the body to return to the
dust in God's timing. But cremation does
not eliminate the hope of a future
resurrection. In fact, many faithful
believers were cremated, albeit
involuntarily,
especially martyrs during the dark ages.
Men like John Hus, William Tinddale,
Polycarp, all of them were burned and
their bodies reduced to ashes. And yet
they will rise again at Christ's return
just as surely as those buried in tombs
and in graves. God who created humanity
from the dust of the earth is certainly
able to resurrect those whose bodies
have returned to the dust or even to
ashes whether by fire by time or even
those who have died at sea. Therefore,
there is no biblical grounds to exclude
someone from the kingdom of heaven
because of the state of their body after
death. What matters is whether the
person belonged to Christ and reflected
his character during their life.
Therefore, the Bible says in
Ecclesiastes 9:10, "Whatever your hand
finds to do, do it with your might,
for there is no work or device or
knowledge or wisdom in the grave where
you are going."
The key according to this verse is to
live faithfully now and so that we may
expect to partake in eternity tomorrow.
Hebrews 10:23 says, "Let us hold fast
the the confession of our hope without
wavering. For he who promised is
faithful." Jesus promises that there is
no need to allow for the management of
our bodies after death to cause us to
lose our hope of eternity. For John 6
37-40 says, "All that the Father gives
me," this is Jesus speaking, "All that
the Father gives me will come to me. And
the one who comes to me, I will by no
means cast out. For I have come down
from heaven, not to do my own will, but
the will of him who sent me. This is the
will of the father who sent me that of
all he has given me I should lose
nothing that's no one but should raise
him up at the last day or raise it up at
at the last day and this is the will of
him who sent me that everyone who sees
the son and believes in him may have
everlasting life and Jesus promises I
will raise him up at the last day
that needs to be submitted to our 3ABN
database that's online
3ABNBibleansers.com.
3abnbbibleansers.com.
You need to submit that. Beautiful.
Praise the Lord.
Yes. Well done.
Amen. Shelley, you have our last
question. Uh, can you please explain 1
Corinthians 15 51-54
and this is from Norin.
Hang on, Norin. This is one of my
favorite scriptures. You know in
revelation
verse uh chapter 20 it talks about
blessed and holy is he who has part in
the first resurrection
and then he says over such the second
death has no power. So I'm going to
we're working our way to 1 Corinthians
15. In John 5:28 and 29
Jesus said this do not marvel at this.
The hour is coming in which all who are
in their graves will hear his voice and
they will come forth those who have done
good to the resurrection of life and
those who have done evil to the
resurrection of condemnation. Many
people don't realize there's two
different resurrections. 1 Thessalonians
4:16-1 17, it's talking about Jesus
second coming. And it says, "The Lord
himself will descend with a shout, with
the voice of an archangel, with a
trumpet of God, and the dead in Christ
will rise first." So, who's in the first
resurrection? The dead in Christ. And
then we who are alive and remain
those who are alive at his coming shall
be caught up together with them in the
clouds to meet the Lord in the air and
thus we shall always be with the Lord.
So what Paul is telling the
Thessalonians, he really unpacks in 1
Corinthians 15:51-54.
Let's look at it. In 1 Corinthians
15:51,
Paul says, "Behold, I tell you a
mystery. We shall not all sleep." That's
a eupheanism for death. "We shall not
all sleep, but we shall all be changed
in a moment, in the twinkling of an eye,
at the last trumpet." This is when
Christ returns. For the trumpet will
sound, the dead will be raised
incorruptible.
So that's the first resurrection. And
those who are alive, he says, "And we
shall be changed. For this corruptable
must put on incorruption, this mortal
must put on immortality."
So when this corruption has put on
incorruption, when this mortal has put
on immortality,
he says, "Then shall be brought to pass
the saying that is written, death is
swallowed up in victory."
Death is an unconscious state.
Ecclesiastes 9:5 and Psalm 146 verse4
describe that. It's described as sleep
by Jesus himself in John 11 11-14.
We sleep in the grave awaiting one of
two resurrections. If we've done good,
the resurrection of life. If we've done
evil, the second resurrection of
condemnation. And when the last trumpet
is sound and Jesus comes forth, this
will be the first resurrection of the
righteous. And that's what we saw it.
Same thing mentioned in 1 Thessalonians
4:16-17.
Then the living righteous are
transformed and immortality
is given then,
not before. God did not create us as
immortal beings. In fact, 1 Timothy 6:15
and 16 says God alone has immortality.
So, we're not gifted
with immortality
until Christ returns. And Paul contrasts
the mortal, the corruptible with a state
of immortality.
So all believers in Christ at his second
coming will be changed. Romans 2:7 says,
"The saved are given the gift of eternal
life and immortality and the final
defeat for the righteous of death will
be when Christ returns and we are
glorified. We will be separated from the
presence of sin forever." Now those who
come up in the second resurrection, the
resurrection of condemnation
will face a second death. You can find
that second death explained by Jesus in
Revelation 2:1 in his own words. Then
also you find it in Revelation 20 verse
6 and 14 and in Revelation 218. So four
times that second death experience, this
is what the unrighteous, the evil and
Satan will all be destroyed. They will
perish in the lake of fire. So then God
creates a new earth and he dwells with
us forever. Revelation 21:4 says he
wipes away every tear. No more death, no
more sorrow, no more crying, no more
pain. For the former things have passed
away.
Amen. Amen. Very, very, very good. Well,
let's uh let's take a quick break. Let's
do an address roll, then we'll come back
and we'll finish up with the last two
minutes.
If you're enjoying our 3AN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us, using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
[Music]
Be sure to include your name and where
you live. And then watch 3abian Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
Welcome back, guys and girls. Do we have
any final thoughts?
Yeah, I think Jamie needs to tell us how
to get his book again.
Yeah, we really want to encourage you to
get your free copy of the book,
Silencing the Accuser, an in uh gospel
investigation of the investigative
judgment. You'll get a free copy right
now if you call into the resource center
at 3ABN for a limited time. One copy is
yours for free. And there's a chapter in
there you're really going to like.
Actually, it's a chapter that the 247
365 guy absolutely hates. It's Hebrews
chap 11 because it describes what the
investigative judgment looks like for a
believer. It mentions, for example, in
Hebrews chap 11 that Noah preached for
120 years faithfully, but it never
mentions that he got drunk in his tent.
It talks about Abraham going out from
the land of going where he didn't know
he was going, but it never talks about
Abraham lying about his wife being his
sister twice. It talks about Moses
leaving the pleasures of sin in Egypt
and and the riches of Pharaoh, but it
doesn't talk about the fact that he
killed an Egyptian and buried him in the
sand. Hebrews 11 is what the
investigative look judgment looks like
for the believer. So, be sure and get
your copy of that book call as soon as
you can.
Amen. Amen. The thought that I wanted to
add was what we were talking about. The
soul is the body of of dust plus the
breath. The spirit the breath of life is
what returns to God like an electrical
charge that's returning to current
that's returning to its source. So at
death if body plus breath equals a soul,
body minus breath, the soul ceases. It's
a big egg there. But at the
resurrection, God reunites that breath
of life with us. He brings us forth.
We've got great hope because death is
not the end. It's just asleep until the
trumpet sounds and we're raised in
glorified bodies.
Amen. And uh Colossians 3:4 says, "When
Christ who is your life appears, then
you also will appear with him in glory."
So, praise the Lord. We can look forward
to that.
Amen. And I just want to thank the three
of you for your hard work for putting
this together. It's fantastic. And I
just want to thank you for spending your
time with us. Just know that we love you
and thank you.
[Music]
Good morning.